In addition to this Places Autocomplete,
we can use other features of the Places
library to add more to our site.
Let's give the user
the ability to search for
places of interest within the map.
>> Instead of using Autocomplete,
I'm going to add a search box to
enhance the users search experience.
Search box predicts what the user
is typing in much the same way as
Autocomplete.
The differences are that search
box supplies an extended list of
predictions, which can include places,
as defined by the Google Places API.
Plus suggested search queries such
as pizza near the Google office.
However, we aren't able to restrict
the search as much as Autocomplete.
>> Let's add the ability for the user
to view nearby points of interest like
restaurants, parks,
museums, etc, in our site.
>> In addition to Place's Autocomplete,
we can use other features of Place's
library to add value to our site.
Let's give the user
the ability to search for
places of interest within the map.
This is going to be a place search.
Instead of using Autocomplete,
I'm going to add a search box to
enhance the user's experience.
Search box predicts
what the user is typing
in much the same way as
Places Autocomplete.
The differences are that search box
applies an extended list of predictions
which can include places,
as defined by the Google Places API.
Plus suggested search queries,
like pizza near the Google office.
However, we aren't able to restrict
the search as much as Autocomplete.
Let's add the ability for the user
to view nearby points of interest
like restaurants, parks,
museums, etc, in our site.
We're going to add one last section to
our HTML here, search for nearby places.
We'll add a new text input,
prompting the user to enter places of
interest search, and another go button.
I'm creating a new search box instance
in the initialized function and
binding it to that text
input that we just created.
I'm also biasing the search box
to within the bounds of the map.
And I'm actually going to create
two event listeners here.
One for when the user selects
an option from the pick list, so
that's our places changed event.
And one if the user
types in something and
clicks go without actually selecting
one of the suggested search queries.
So that's our click event.
I'm creating a global placemarkers
array here to use in both functions, so
we can control the markers separately
from our listings markers.
And so that we have only one set of
placemarkers on our map at a time.
Also, remember our
hideListings function?
This one iterated through
our markers array, and
set the map to null on
all of the markers.
We're actually going to expand
that to make it generic.
By making the markers array
a variable that I pass into this,
I actually allow us to use it for
all of our sets of markers.
So we're going to use this any
time we want to hide an array of
markers on the map.
Everywhere we used this before,
I'm just going to pass in markers,
which is our global listings array.
I'm also going to use it now to
control our placemarkers array.
Now let's create the function that will
execute when the user chooses a picklist
value from the searchBox,
I'm calling it searchBoxPlaces.
When a user enters a value, they
will be given common search queries.
When the user then chooses one of
those values from the options given in
the search box, first,
we'll hide any place markers we have
on the map from our last search.
Then, we'll find all the places
that match our query.
We'll do this using
the searchBox.getPlaces method, and
assign them all into this Places array.
If we didn't find any places,
we'll alert that to the user.
If we do find places, we'll then call
this, createMarkersForPlaces function,
which we'll define soon.
And pass in our Places array.
We're separating this out, because, in
both our search box places function, and
our text search function.
Which is the other event listener that
we created, we'll do the same thing.
Now we'll define our text
search places function.
So again, this is the function
that will execute if,
instead of choosing a value
from the pick list,
the user enters a search query or a
location and then clicks on a go button.
First, we'll capture
the bounds of the map.
Then, we'll hide any existing
placemarkers that may already be
on the map.
We'll then create a new
places service instance and
call the text search function.
We'll pass in our user-entered query and
the bounds of the map.
When we get the results back, which is
the Places array, if the status is okay,
we'll call the same
createMarkersForPlaces function,
passing in that Places array.
Let's create this
createMarkersForPlaces function now.
Okay, so at this point, we've gotten
an array of places back from both
our places service text search and
our searchBox.getPlaces method.
What we need to do with these
places is iterate through them and
create a marker per place.
So for each of the places in this
places array we'll capture a bunch
of the information about the place.
We'll get the icon which
we'll use as the marker icon.
This is either a fork and knife for
a restaurant, a martini glass for
a bar etc.
It's just kind of a cute feature.
We'll get the place name,
which we'll use as the marker title.
We'll get the place's location, which
we'll use as the marker's position, and
we'll capture the place
ID as the marker ID.
We'll use that place ID later so
that we can more details if
a user clicks on that marker.
We'll push each marker that we create
into our placeMarkers array, and
we'll adjust the balance of
the map to appropriately fit
all of the placeMarkers that we return.
By default 20 places are returned
in both of these searches.
Let's test out both searches.
First, I'm going to I'm going to
enter a search query and
choose one from the pick list.
These are all of our places.
It's pretty concentrated here.
Next I'm going to enter a query and
click the Go button.
So far we can see the title if
we hover over the marker but
we're going to need to get a lot
more details about these places.
We'll find out how to do
that in the next lesson.
>> Let's take a break before getting
all the details about these places
to see just how fast Autocomplete is.